we are back and we are poaching midnight
here in the Garden of Good and Evil so
let's bring out our next presenter
please welcome a great actor an Oscar
winner Denzel Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the only members of our Academy of Arts
and Sciences who can make pictures
without any of the rest of us are those
who are both artists and scientists on
our sets we know them as the DP the
director of photography our
cinematographers Janusz Kaminski 4aa
Mustafa
[Music]
[Applause]
Roger Deakins for Kundu
[Music]
Dante's been ot4 le confidential
[Applause]
Russell carpenter for Titanic
Edoardo Santa for the wings of the duck
and the Oscar goes to
Russell carpenter
[Applause]
this is Russell confidence
[Applause]
and furminator to 3d
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for running so late
this is becoming sort of it depends
moment for me but I want to remind
everybody that that it was only it was a
year ago exactly to this day that we
wrapped principal photography on Titanic
and what a year it's been it's gone from
being a ship of fools to a ship of
dreams and that's Jim Jim all the way he
stuck to his guns thank you Jim
I want to thank my crew they take some
serious Stern and and I love them for it
and my wife Patricia you saved me in
every way a person can be saved
thank you I love you
[Applause]
[Music]